all right we're going to begin this hour
with new music from the indie pop band
they're called lucious we think you're
going to like here's a listen
[Music]
are you dancing around your bedroom the
kitchen or the living room yeah that's
heartburst from their just released
album second nature is a return to the
spotlight for front women
jess jess wolfe and holly lessig in
recent years they've become elite backup
singers for major acts anthony mason met
up with the parrot wolf's los angeles
home now he first met them back in 2018
of course anthony did a lot has changed
since then anthony good morning good
morning jess and holly say it's become
second nature to help each other process
what's happening in their lives through
songwriting every lucious song begins
over coffee talks so we join them for a
cup
[Music]
jess wolfe and holly lessig have always
had something special in the studio
[Music]
when did you first know that
the first time we sang together it was
really interesting because we have very
different voices on our own
but when we get together it's almost
like we become
each other
[Music]
as the group lucious they've become one
of indie pop's most acclaimed live acts
you guys have basically been together
now for what 16 years
it been that long
yeah i guess end of 2005 yeah we met
when we were 10
[Laughter]
they met at berkeley college of music in
boston where they didn't just find each
other i think community
is something that we
both struggled
with having
as
young people we found your community i
did yeah i always described going to
music school as like
the moment in that blind melon video
where the little b
finds all the other bees in the field
that's what it felt like today
i love that they set out to make it in
new york was this basically your first
cover story
yeah in the iconic city paper the
village voice in 2016. it was a big deal
when that happened dad had it framed
their breakthrough came at south by
southwest in austin texas it was a
magical show you could hear a pin drop
yeah and we got a publishing deal and a
record deal from that show
[Music]
[Applause]
jess and holly's distinctive sound has
made them popular collaborators so in
demand working with harry styles brandy
carlisle and touring with roger waters
that they took time off from making
their own music i think we were excited
at that point to be
a part of someone else's machine for a
little bit i mean just to get right to
the heart of things i was going through
a really difficult time in my marriage
my
my husband was
he's still our band mate
and um
i think we were
ready to
experience something else
by the time lucius finally got back
together to make their new album jess
and her husband dan molad the band's
drummer had divorced we hadn't seen each
other since we got divorced at that
point it was like a year and a half i
mean a lot of people would say how do
you do that how do you go back into a
band with somebody you split from
yeah honestly
it's
it was probably a big reason why we
didn't split for a long time
because we didn't want to lose that yeah
yeah but you don't have to you know
we've both found love again i think
we've both
gotten to a place where we felt like
i'm so glad that you're still
my friend
for holly the world has also changed you
have a baby now i do and he's going on
tour with you
that's the plan
we'll see how he likes it
it's a new kind of party on the tour bus
have you called friends who've done it
and said how the hell do you do this
and and also just logistics like so what
kind of pack and play fits on a tour bus
[Music]
for their new album second nature they
went for a disco vibe
[Music]
i think we were stir crazy and we wanted
to dance they worked with the
grammy-winning dave cobb known for
producing chris stapleton jason isbell
and brandy carlisle but dave cobb
doesn't make disco records he does yeah
he won it was his idea and carlisle
asked to co-produce
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when we sat in on lucius rehearsing for
their upcoming tour brandy dropped in to
say hi
and sing backup
[Music]
jess and holly say it was carlisle who
pushed them to be more grandiose
[Music]
we always said no we can't do that
she's like yeah you can
and you will
[Music]
i know as someone who's been in the
audience
i can get chills hearing the two of you
sing do you ever give yourself chills
when you sing
the sweet questions
oh we sound good
definitely
[Music]
yeah i'm getting chills all over again i
know amazing these two are so amazing
together it really i mean something
happens when when they sing and it and
obviously all these other artists have
seen it too because they all want them
to come on tour or record with it i love
that reversal of brandon carlisle now
the backup backups for them exactly and
dave cobb producing like a disco vibe
yeah well they i mean they basically
said you know the coming out of the
pandemic is so many they kind of like
wanted they wanted to dance and and so
this disco record came out all this
which is not their typical thing but
it's a lot of fun it's a great record
yeah brandi says i want to produce can i
produce it yeah the answer is yes and i
love that jess and her ex are able to be
in the band together isn't that amazing
yes it is it's amazing their whole
approach was so thoughtful it was like
you know this is still important to us
yeah and so we want to still be together
and their voices are good too
[Laughter]
and they sound good going on tour with
an ex-husband and no by the way a baby
yes all right good luck if anyone can do
it they can anthony thank you very much